foreign
hello everyone we are going to do a
another layer of discussion about
multi-computation and lazy functions
and uh
Nick has we sort of decided we weren't
going to have a generic lazy expression
but Nick has been investigating that and
has interesting things to talk about
here
so go ahead why don't you do your demo
explain what's going on
so well first of all so the the
like the motivation for this thing was
to actually develop something that's not
just immutable expression that is in
some way lazy right because it was kind
of hard
to program with it when you actually
have to have some cash and things like
that right so I try to make this General
thing like an expression within some
sense have this mutability property
so which Expressions do not have
in general yeah
yeah all the expressions are immutable
right
but somehow lazy Expressions the idea is
that they're not important I I try to
make them immutable and see what is
going to lead me to
and you mean you mean you tried to make
them mutable
yeah mutable right wage expression is
immutable thing
so it's like it's like because um by a
bunch of Dynamics around it also like
duration
so I just want to clarify is it is it
visibly mutable or is it just mutable in
you know secretly in order to do cashing
it's very visibly mutable that's the
idea it's like I'm gonna show you okay
this is like represents a mutable
expression which is also lazy so just
contain some kind of code that you can
evaluate so if this is like you can
click around it it relates right you can
click like some inner Expressions you
can relate them in any way and it's
mutable in a sense that it's actually
propagates for whatever whenever it
appears right it's like triggers all the
Dynamics and actual structure and I will
have this lazy expression later on it's
still the same kind of thing
okay
right if you construct it from scratch
it's another one there's a possibility
to Cache it if like I can turn on the
cache and if I construct the same
expression again it's going to link to
the same kind of thing
and if it's already you've been
evaluated I'm gonna emulate it twice
again okay all right visibility and you
can like maybe if you have a separate
one
expression
this is like a actual symbol that is
assigned
now it's like in order to make it
mutable I can
talk about how it actually implemented
it's like assign the symbol this data
structure value right if you make this
pin now links to this value that is
immutable okay but hold on so if I say
laser expression one plus two times
three comma B
yeah that is a different expression from
one plus two times three comma a is that
correct yeah that's going to be a
different one okay so that's like a
it's like there's the content and
there's some kind of tag
that indicates that that core reference
if we don't provide the second language
it's going to be like some unique symbol
you can see it's like ref door
114 there
if I provide it it's going to be
tagged with a
if I make it the same one again it's
going to leak it's gonna try to assign
to the same thing but but it can
it basically can't assign it anymore so
I have to make
it like reference it
all right well keep going because we're
not not so far I don't really understand
but go ahead yeah okay so what what
other things you like well we are pretty
pretty much already showed you how to
reference each other if I make a bunch
of these lazy Expressions well first of
all if I construct a one a lazy
expression like X here and then use it
within other expression and kind of
propagates itself
up right to construct a new release
expression so we can have like nested
things that reference each other right
so you construct the next lines mean
dotted lines is like impossible to
relate them it's not a lazy reference
inside of it but some kind of
sub-expression with value queue
basically you can just evaluate it
and it's gonna like roll it in place
construct a bunch of things that
reference each other
there's like limitations that they have
like built in that it's not looks
within some
like two levels deep into the formatting
so but I can like I know
make very deep evaluation
I don't understand this at all well
Dynamics is pretty it's crazy looking
it's like this is represents a
self-reference so basically if this is
the laser expression this is the thing
that where it's a reference itself I I
like the use of that emoji for that
why not to use it so this is represented
some different returns like maybe this
one
right they're all dependent on each
other
why it's like now you can even do the
graph of references
so you can ask for any of those lazy
expressions and they will evaluate
enough to see what reference it contains
and see kind of this dependency things
and again you click on them inside the
graph yeah just for maximal Insanity oh
my God okay
yeah they're crazy
yeah so yeah maybe I will generate them
because
they like reference each other they can
expand exponentially
I'm gonna look crazy
so
this is kind of if
anybody familiar like with rasco
programming they have this lazy
non-strict semantics of relation in the
lazy expression is essentially a funk
it's some kind of code reference in that
that lives in a heap that you can
evaluate right and what forces an
evaluation in this such kind of
languages is part of matching as soon as
you pattern match against this
Funk or lazy expression the path to it
that only sufficiently to pattern match
against it that are going to be
evaluated so it's like
if you create some kind of expression
like this right it's not related
anything yet
I can ask whether it's a list or not
right
you can't you can tell yes it's list and
nothing in this expression being
evaluated to answer this question
I cannot answer ask whether it contains
Plus or times here
and still evoluted nothing but as soon
as I ask for something like
to check whether this first element of
this list is integer it would force
evaluation
of this particular thing
so now it becomes accumulated
so it's a pretty bizarre idea here I
mean the claim is
there is an expression
and it can be in its unevaluated form
or it can go through and be evaluated so
for example let's say that my match was
it's a thing of length two
okay yeah then
in its unevaluated form
it could be
you know let's say oh it's a thing of
length one okay
because it's in its unevaluated form it
says range of a thousand and that's a
thing of length one
but range of a thousand is also a thing
of length of a thousand so which one is
it
that's what I'm saying
well if it's a range
if it's a laser range it will
evaluate enough to answer this question
no I I know that but I'm asking the
question
range of a thousand
at some level that's of length one but
at some level that's the length of a
thousand
so is it the case that when you are
defining these things that what you mean
is
that
is as if it is fully evaluated
is that correct
well in what sense this is link one I
don't understand look at the look at the
original expression range of a thousand
it's length one as a as a pure in the
same you can check the head look no
in the same sense that two plus two is
underscore plus matches underscore Plus
two plus two no more matches underscore
plus than range of a thousand is of
length one
well if you have this kind of button
then yeah in order to answer this kind
of query you have to read the range
no but but look underscore plus is
matching the unevaluated two plus two
yeah right why do you why are you
allowed to match the unevaluated
anything because if you can match
unevaluated things then range around
matches
a thing of length one
go ahead if you do length of unevaluated
of range of a thousand that gives one
right
yes no doubt it does although it's
unclear I mean if you did this in
general it's unclear what you would you
know what you'd actually feed into the X
so that it would you know you can't just
do hold of the expression because it
might you know that that's not the same
as the expression yeah nothing you could
put in there that would that would
actually works semantics is not properly
defined what I'm claiming is there is a
semantics that is pattern match against
the fully resolved version of this
currently lazy expression
so the semantics is like you
structurally look at the expression with
the head doesn't match you fully
evaluate it that's not reasonable it's
not going to work
it's mushy right because you know it's
one thing to say the pattern match is
against the final unlazy you know eager
form right which you may or may not
actually generate that's up to you
whether you actually generate it but
these semantics is the pattern matching
is against that
or the pattern matching is against the
thunk generator
which is quite different
am I making sense
well if you have like lazy expression
with it it still can contain function
generator that generates at least you
know okay no you understand what I'm
saying I'm saying you can't have it both
ways you can't both match
if two plus two is the lazy expression
that cannot be matched to underscore
Plus
is what I'm saying
okay so now if you say match Q of that
comma underscore Plus
okay I think that's just wrong percent
72 okay so if you say match Q represent
72 comma underscore integer
I'm just going to yeah okay
okay I claim both these cannot both be
true
I claim that's just going to blow up the
world to have both of those be true
it's either one or the other it's either
has head Plus or it has head integer
can't have both heads
you see what I'm saying
no sure well
that's because we dealing with this
mutable stuff
it's not because it's mutable it's not
because it's mutable it's because it's
not probably defined semantics I mean
it's it's either look those two lines
are inconsistent
right I mean really it should just say
it matches lazy expression and what
happens if you say head of percent 72
anyway
because normally head of head of you
know hash equals is equivalent to match
Q if it comma underscore block
oh my God okay
uh
wow
so is it does it consume absolutely
everything or could you say something
like hold is there any is there anything
too much does it because you can see
match queue just worked on the match
I didn't right the match before match is
a special case
nice expressions
what's that yeah
what has a match key it has enough value
for everything but it has a special up
value for matched Q yeah yeah
and also replace at this point here
color me unconvinced here does that mean
that you can't put a match Q into the
lazy expression directly
oh you can try it
in this way if you could want to like
have a benefit of this automatic value
then you can but you can obviously make
a lazy expression and just put my
chicken
okay all right
I'm just not convinced by us but keep
going because let's understand what you
figured out
about
laser expressions in general so keep
going here
well and then after building this kind
of crazy thing I try to visit lazy lists
again but using this kind of technology
or whatever so let's have to in the
invent this kind of lazy range
ping I use in a different
Constructor now because they're still
using the same old packet so the lazy
range with mutable immutable list is
still there so I have to use it by the
way presumably if you clicked I mean if
you click on these these little dotted
areas in the wrong order you can just
make it totally explode can't you
sure but that's quite cool leading
towards multi-computation you can it
really is what in whatever order you
want
well right except that this program you
know presumably cares that it be
evaluated in a sensible order
yeah
it's like there's some default semantics
how lists should be related
for example right now it's always
regulates the first element that is
contains some kind of not emulated code
and ignores what go if if there's
anything after that
for example
all right so let me just understand
something so
there's multiple things going on here so
one thing is this idea of the
partially evaluated expression
where you can control the evaluation
path by clicking
right yeah
right and and so imagine that this was a
proof
okay and imagine that you were
you know imagine this was kind of like a
almost a proof assistant type situation
um
and
I think it would be like at least some
typing would be required you know to
actually make it useful for proof
assistance
especially if you think about something
like proof assistance and lean if any of
those lazy Expressions has actually some
type
assigned to them
then it would be exactly
like any what can any
strictly typed language okay but but I
mean
what we're looking at here
I'm a little bit confused here so
we can imagine forget the proof thing
for a second and just talk about
you know evaluation in the sense of
Ian's evaluation graphs Trace graphs
rather
this thing
could represent a uh okay in a trace
graph what is this is this a a
transversal of a trace crop what is this
what is one of these objects
is it a slice at one level of a trace
graph
where you can then say
I will click something to follow an edge
in the trace graph
is that right or is that not right
yeah it's kind of close if you have a
multi
multi-way version of the trace graph you
can when you have an option to go an ID
Direction
not just for in default to variation no
I understand that so I mean but but
you're saying
right and you click and it follows a
time-like edge is that correct
there could be
it can be multiple branches but every
time you click you're following a
particular time like Edge to another
state
is that right
yeah but in this case it's also
immutable state
well this is just for performance
Reasons I'm sorry can I go ahead can I
ask is when you click does that do a
single evaluation or is that like an
infinite evaluation to a fixed point
when you click on something
well if you if you have like a
definition like this then it's just one
it tries to do one evaluation as much as
possible
if there's some explosion going on
underneath here that I can't control
which is gonna explode sorry
you can see the definition of the laser
range for example it
the laziness comes because the
explicitly generates Xbox track there
so that's what stops it
even though it's recursive that's what
stops it to go infinitely
could we see x equals X plus one or does
that not make any sense
no we can totally do this
it's like I can this is like a different
buttons I'm clicking there's like one
for evaluation and one to evaluate
references
go ahead but you're not just clicking
you're you're pressing a key or
something yeah yeah like option key if I
press option key and then click it I can
evaluate only the reference really quite
crazy
I can do this like this foreign
what
that
could you go back to the lazy expression
of x equal x plus one do
I mean like I see this is like a
self-referential thing but what it like
on a separate input do lazy expression
of x equal x plus one well this is well
first of all this now is just a hold of
this X plus one the dust box says that
there's a value assigned to X so this is
itself can evaluate as soon as evaluated
it relates to the lazy expression again
so that's why it's okay it's a reference
what does that mean what does that emoji
mean
it means that this box it has a
reference and this is the
this sub expression references itself
it's like this the Emoji represents the
whole expression it presents yeah and it
represents you know percent 79 kind of
thing
okay
all right so click something once
to go one level More Level so I want to
see it should be blah plus two or
something should be something you can
get
well if I just click on the box I can
evaluate this expression just with the
twitching all the references inside or
any lazy expression as a symbol purely
symbolically right in this case it's
gonna maybe like just sort it because
plus is all the rest okay so then what
cook it again if we click it again
nothing happens already I have to
resolve the reference
right as soon as the reference is
resolved
it's like once I get the same expression
because it's what because it's
mutable it's already mutated so it's
like a new one
okay well so do it again
click it again okay why did that go
three did you click it twice then normal
I clicked it once because it is there's
one reference that reference itself but
it was referenced in the mutable thing
so it's kind of
no I like it well it added another layer
of the already mutated thing not the
original thing it started with it's like
if I resolve this reference again
there's going to be four more once again
show me
because that that self-reference is to
that whole thing with eight ones now
yeah to the whole box not dust
okay now how did you resolve the ones
can you now resolve the ones somehow
expression
I click on the whole expression
where the reference just tweeted as a
symbol
okay I don't understand in terms of
evaluation Trace graphs and so on what
did you just do
I adjust the related the outermost
expression
and that's it
okay
okay
all right can you just do x equals like
the expression of list X comma X and see
the tree version
okay to throw it again what what x
equals lazy expression of list X comma X
comma X yep
binary tree
yep
Okay so
okay and how do I go one more level
there
what did you just do what did you click
did you click the same thing or you
click a different thing
I clicked on the this is I resolved the
reference the left one
so let me start from the beginning again
here just to re-evaluate it so emulate
this one what did that do what did that
do it related X itself
because X is just this lazy expression
and a lazy expression reference
okay and then when you evaluated it it
said now I'm a reference to the whole of
the self
yes
okay
all right now click it again
now should I just click nothing happens
I have to click it with the option key
or something well I want the option key
doing what's the option key oh it's just
the convenience there's like two
axes that they can relate either just
evaluate an expression or it is all the
reference it's just
to do for a better control of this thing
okay so wait a minute so resolving okay
in that expression
the the first boxed X
how do you resolve its reference
like this one yes that one there
well you just evaluate this expression
okay no no no no no no no no no no no
that on its in and of itself you just
click it is that right
well yeah I can click it either
no just click it okay that does that
that's what I expected okay now
if you click inside the box that left
box
what will that do will that resolve
anything or not or are there no
references to resolve there well there
are references but but there's nothing
to evaluate it's not only so I'm
clicking right now it evaluates this
without resolving this self-references
so it's not doing anything
okay
but can but I can resolve any of those
or both of them together
and it's going to explize the whole
outer boxes in place of those not show
it
oh God
okay
ah
so every one of the self-references was
now uh replaced by the current state of
what that outer
square box was outer filled box was yep
okay
all right well you've got a couple more
demos to show there and I want to go
back to what on Earth this all means
yeah no there's like a classic oh this
is basically the same thing that's about
but this is a few versions of obligatory
Fibonacci ones
because I'm gonna go crazy this is one
very explosive
and it's like
this one is less explosive
I don't want to be put there
I know what's going on something broken
is it oh it's probably in
a problem that's because we've created a
reference
above
okay
so let's understand the bigger picture
here okay
first question is
how is this relevant okay our original
objective
is to represent multi-computation
yes is this relevant to that
well I think I think it is
the main thing that you're introducing
here is this notion of a
self-referential structure is that
correct
well some of the main things or
references in general there's some
called expressions and I can reference
them and mutate them
not just software purposes
okay let's review where we were at
before
we have a concept of lazy list
we understand that there are operations
we can do and then at the end we resolve
it
how does this relate to that
like before
range
okay
I was like this before yes yes yes yes
yes yes yes and now we say on that lazy
range let's just remind us of what we do
we are able to say in lazy range
you know uh select Prime cue of cash and
even Q of hash on the lazy range
okay now what happens here okay now
so
okay so now how do we resolve this
the thing we just you just gave there
how will we resolve that
I've done something broke
ah
yeah
let me kill it
hello I just modified something so sure
what
okay
okay
and it's not obvious that that can work
I mean it's not obvious
because it
I mean it doesn't need to prove a
theorem basically
to make that work
to resolve that to two
yeah it should well that's why it's kind
of stuck
because I pressed the infinite
evaluation one
it's like nice yeah that's helpless so I
mean if we just say
you know in that Amazon say Ampersand
hash less than a thousand or something
just to make it
yeah
well and and and and hash less than a
thousand
well that would be
trivial that's okay now that should
resolve completely
okay keep pressing it because now it
should just resolve
I'm not sure about that
oh it still can't resolve I see it still
can't resolve because it doesn't even
know it doesn't know what's going to be
in the lazy rage fine
okay
yeah
so we have to go to a meta level to deal
with this that is we have to go out to
the operating system and kill the
process
yeah
okay
all right so let's go back again to
remind ourselves what we're trying to do
right the real objective which we don't
seem to be following here which we
really need to follow is the
implementation of multi-computation I've
said this you know many times replacing
our multi-way functions with something
else
is what you're doing here contributing
to that or not
well if you can see the Multiverse
system is like
what multi-computation is not not really
this tries to be
you know something more General
okay well let's try to understand what
it is
okay yeah so so I see it's like we need
some ways to define a bunch of
semantics of how we compute stuff
not just evaluating outermost
expressions
like that even lazy or not but
in general any kind of evaluation
technique
somehow customizable
and control
and by controllable we mean you press
things and random things happen and
sometimes you have to go out to the
operating system to kill it
well pressing just making a nice
formatting is just a
nice visualization but it's not the
point right it just makes it better make
sense of it
okay no I understand but I'm I'm trying
to understand your concept here is
usually
the kind of the overall
sort of prime mover of everything is the
evaluator
that is in standard in in the language
in the standard situation is there is an
expression every time it's presented the
evaluator takes a crack at it and does
something to it right it's kind of like
in the universe or something you can
imagine it's like like there's a thing
that's just apply the rule apply the
rule apply the rule there's a meta thing
that is that we think of as being the
apply the rule rule if you understand
what I'm saying now what I think you're
doing here is to try to deconstruct that
concept
by saying that instead of having an
apply the rule rule
you're instead saying
you're going to do that with assignments
like x equals thing of x
that's your way of defining I mean in
other words
the generic evaluator would just be
x equals a vowel of x
that's equivalent to
well I I I think do you understand what
I'm saying
well not yet
okay so what I'm saying is
the usual evaluator
is like fix but you know you use let's
say there's let's say you call the
evaluator a vowel
okay
then saying x equals the vowel of x
the fixed point of x equals the value of
x is x equals you know Nest to Infinity
of eval on x
yeah
okay so I'm saying that you could write
you're saying you want a flexible way of
representing an evaluation like process
so what I'm saying is the existing
evaluation process is Nest to Infinity
of a vowel on x
which you could also write as x equals a
vowel of x
so to see what I'm saying so far
and but what you are claiming I'm not
sure I agree with you
is that you have a more general form of
evaluation
by being able to say instead of just
saying x equals a value of x
you can say x equals f of x comma G of X
or something
and that's a more general form of a
valuation-like activity but what okay
what you're doing here you are
describing an infinite data structure
by self-reference
and then you're equating
evaluation
with some kind of end result in that
infinite data structure if I'm not
mistaken
is that correct
any by querying you all the questions
you want to ask you do by querying this
data structure yeah
okay but the the the whole point here is
normally in the language we have and in
almost everything we do we have the
notion of there isn't a vowel
uh this is where we went through again
before which is what we need this you
know the the thing where we've got
replacement rules we've got function
application
and we've got this thing that you're now
doing which you're now conflating a yet
different thing into this which we were
talking about you know down value
computation as a as a as a okay
when you say what did we call it last
time we had um
multi
multi-way
Nest right what do we call it multi what
were we calling it
laziness tree
yes but multi-way nest
takes our
you could write multi-way nest if you
wanted to write it as a self-referential
equation you could
what multi-way Nest does
right multi-way Nest is just x equals
list f of x comma G of X for example
am I right
well in this case you'd say x equals
list X plus one two x
right that's that's what that is if I'm
not mistaken correct
I don't know where you put the one there
I don't know where you put the one
that's the starting point for the
multi-way nest where do you put that
well what's pink
it would be like x equals
lazy expression of tree of one comma
X plus one two x
right
yeah
I don't know still the list yeah right
so hold on so what is that giving us now
so yeah
did I think this is something slightly
different because of the fact that the
X's refer to the whole
expression
yeah well you have to stop at some point
so you may relate it you write some
tablet or so then you get rid of this
self-references you basically
finalize your tree
and then you can show it
okay look look do you understand what
I'm I mean the point that I'm making is
what we've got previously multi-way Nest
multi-way replace they have well
understood
ways to move forward
am I making sense
you seem to be defining a new way to
move forward by using self-reference
am I making sense
yeah and it's more it is more aligned
with what other things well other people
are doing
for better or worse because they haven't
managed to get very far in what they're
doing so I'm not that interested
it's like how it's working yeah I
understand that I understand that and
it's but it's you know it's not that's
not the problem we're trying to solve
particularly yeah
but at least some motivation is there I
think worth exploring
up to a point
I mean I don't get it okay show me where
you know great you know there's this
amazing technology and we'd like to
understand uh
the um
um
you know infinite data structures and
make use of them and so on but nobody's
doing stuff with infinite data
structures for real that I know of
you know there are yes in principle you
could have that but it's not something
where you know we talked about this
multiple times we've talked about
canonical forms problems we've talked
about a bunch of other things you know I
I don't okay
okay let's go through this again
what are we really getting here
we've got something where
I mean I just I'm sorry I really don't
understand I don't understand what the
point of this is
other than some kind of Paradigm to work
with
to better work with this kind of
infinite data structures
so then what you're saying is
okay
see this is where I I think one is
getting confused all right one way of
parameterizing an infinite data
structure is through self-reference it
is certainly not the only way of having
an infinite data structure it is one way
of parameterizing it
am I making sense
oh yeah basically it's a graph
and all the whole computation on it
boils down to graph reduction
well fine but let's imagine you have a
combinator expression
okay and it's going to as you as you
evaluated it's going to generate an
infinite sequence of combinator
expressions
okay
so is that easily representable here for
example the the non-terminating S
combinator expression is that easily
representable here
maybe if it we can just Define it
like this and make it a lazy expression
oh oh look what's in it
uh I always have to look it up which is
embarrassing but it's it's it's that of
why of X isn't it or something I forget
which order it's in
Okay so
I can look up hold on
just I'll look up what the actual
expression is
foreign
no it's X of Z of Y of Z by the way that
first thing X of Z of Y of Z
okay and now the first
non-terminating s
expression is
okay I'll put it in I'll send it to you
there's two of them
now you can take one of those
let's take the first one of those
okay that should be a non-terminating
thing
what's that
oh
he's died what died it got into a
infinite look again
ah
well it's hard to control
yes I know I know that's why I don't
think this is so useful
because the whole point is I mean again
to give the meta lecture about language
design right the goal of language design
is have people do things that work
oh just make it better no I don't think
that's correct conclusion I I'm sorry I
don't think it's the correct conclusion
I think it's the type of mistake that
was made with prologue for example where
people routinely Define things where you
just it would just go off into La La
Land
and that's why it never really worked in
practice is because the
you know you you define something which
is you know explosive right and and
whenever you do that a language design
it's just a bad idea
you know
so let's go through this again right
well it doesn't mean it's wrong it's
like okay it's not wrong it's just not
useful right I mean so you can define a
lot of languages that are that are you
know not wrong I mean it just the whole
point is to define something that is a
what we're really trying to do is we're
trying to have a way so that people like
us can use multi-computation in practice
right so as soon as we have something
where every time you press the wrong
button the whole spacecraft explodes it
doesn't really work very well
like we want something where you know
it's like like you could imagine
something where
you're you have an airplane and
you know
the controls do things like uh you know
that's a good example I mean maybe I'm
Too airplane specific but I mean in in
I don't know what you know
but
you want controls where that where most
of you know the easy to control stuff
does something is actually useful turns
the airplane things like that rather
than that the easier to control thing
puts it in a tail spin
if you understand me well it's clear
that you have to come up with the easy
controls
but it's not like find the waste buff is
going to view this easy control that
solves everything no I agree but I think
it's useful it's understandable it's
useful there's a there's a whole class
of problems that it can deal with
right so what you're doing here is
you've got potentially a sort of super
powerful thing here
where most of the times it's going to
blow up
right
or if you click the buttons maybe but
the point is to have the code like find
replace pop that it's just a data
structure it doesn't have to be some
interactable thing at all no no I
understand that but I'm I'm what I'm
attacking here
and I think you know given that you're
studying this right let's see if we can
turn this into something that is more
useful okay
what you're saying is one way to
represent the progress of computation is
through self-reference
right x equals a vowel of x
that is a way to represent the process
of infinite evaluation am I am I correct
well usually that's how defined yes I
know I know but that particular okay
that okay the question is do you want to
change at the level of
the self-referential structure that is a
way where unraveling the
self-referential structure
is equivalent to a Time sequence of
evaluation
am I making sense because the
self-referential structure is not a Time
sequence it's just a self-referential
structure
does that make sense
well yeah you can have this structure
which is a graph and the reduction would
be it's going to be represented as a
state in the mutual system itself
so that you can evaluate it in different
orders
what's a normal what what's part of no
delete the expression here or the self
proliferation graph that you want to
reduce is a state in the Multiverse
system right when the transition is
going to be evaluating some of it
somewhat part maybe resolving some
self-reference okay so that's one way of
doing this that we actually considered
in the physics project and I have an
incredibly obscure note in the um
uh and the technical introduction of the
physics project
which says
you could consider
encoding the whole history
of every state in a state
do you see what I'm saying so in other
words
when you get to
for example instead of having a an atom
of space called 13
that atom of space could package inside
it the whole
provenance and lineage of that atom of
space where it came from so to speak
yeah it's history right
if you do that
you do not make any progress the
universe will never progress all it is
is just a self-referential structure
that
you know is is not particularly useful
because any Observer of it has to
resolve it to some extent
you know seeing it in its
self-referential form
okay so you know the issue would be
you could say oh but it is a more useful
definition I mean you could imagine I
don't think it's true but you could
imagine that the right way to represent
multi-computational processes is
implicitly by virtue of their what in
physics might be called self-consistent
equations
am I making sense
I don't know how physics we have a few
physics people here but but um uh I mean
at least Jose probably like like I mean
to go physically like the beta Soul
Peter equation is a good example of this
where you're representing a bound State
and you're saying the bound state is
equal to some operator acting on the
bound state
um
maybe that was not useful for anybody
but but that's a you know there is a
motif this idea there's showing a Dyson
equations are the same way in physics
the these self-consistent equations like
that
generally those things have not been
very useful
I mean they're a representation and
they're kind of neat they're like
generating function type thing they can
be that that well they're not like
generating functions but they are you
can kind of unravel them
like generating functions if that makes
sense
no this kind of thing you also kind of
know you can imagine solving an equation
when you resolve this Opera I know I
know I know I'm saying that the history
of such self-consistent equations is at
least in physics isn't I think not
particularly good
right and and I think in in this
computational setting it seems very
questionable
I don't know maybe it's useful it's it's
usually hard for people to understand
blows up easily and you know isn't a
good representation I think
but convince me otherwise I mean you
know like like for example let's imagine
that you had a theory of of infinite
self-referential data structures okay
that was based on these things it would
be like saying you know we could we
could translate to transfinite numbers
you know something the expression x
equals f of x could be some kind of
thing that or you say how what is the
length of
you know or the or the tree version of
that right x equals f of x comma X
okay can somebody else help me out here
is
I I I think this is not a good Branch
but I don't know
so I mean I'm and I think we we you know
we have a definite Branch to follow I
don't think this is a good
representation of multi-computation I
think it is not a useful for humans
representation but I might be wrong
and the fact that if we do an example
here it blows up it's not a great sign
because that's what I would have
expected would happen
right
well I wouldn't cling to that particular
blow up
no but I understand but I'm saying to
you I don't think
okay you could make these things that
are self
referential
you know
objects that are defined by
self-reference
okay
I I just don't know how to make those
I you know unless you have a cantor-like
representation of the results of a piece
of self-reference like that unless you
can symbolify the result of the
self-reference I don't think it's going
to work
reference is basically how all the lazy
expressions are resolved you just
strip away the necessary parts that you
need I I know but I'm saying that having
this General case of self-reference I
don't think is going to be useful
because I think that the majority of
cases people will Define will just blow
up
oh I'm not necessarily agree with that
because
of a language of Costco like the world
every data structure useful one is a
self-referential one
okay Christopher can you make a comment
about this
uh
I don't know I mean I I just think that
the more concrete you know lazy lists
and so on is just it's much more clear
what to do and it's much more uh clearly
useful than if it's everything is just
this sort of unstructured maybe
self-referential
noodle soup
but I mean let's try to understand what
we can get given that you've done a
whole bunch of work on this let's try
and figure out what we can learn from it
okay
and simply saying it should work because
it sort of works for Haskell I don't
think it's really that useful I think
what we need to understand is you know
okay we know we're trying to represent
certain kinds of things in terms of
multi-computation
um I don't know is James here
yes
can you comment on I mean you know if
you look at this and you imagine this in
terms of ruly ads and end machines and
all this kind of thing is this going to
provide a useful representation of any
of that stuff
it's it's hard to say because
personally the kind of the the design of
it at the moment is somewhat of a
somewhat of a barrier it seems kind of
it seems to prohibit or impede some
understanding of my part maybe this
could be presented in an easier way but
it's hard for me to follow let me let me
just let me just cut this back again
this is okay in physics for example this
is a pretty common idea
that you know maybe Jose wants to
comment on this it's a pretty common
idea to make up self-consistent
equations for things
Jose do you want to do you want to make
a comment on that
I know this is done in in quantum
mechanics but it's not that familiar to
me
um yeah I guess you're referring to
bootstrap methods and things like that
yes
yes it is it is a form of uh you know I
mean the most common cases are things
like the Dyson equation the Bison
equation they're all of the form x
equals f of x
they are for example very typical cases
a bounce State okay particles bound
together you know and the the concept is
you know your atom is your atom plus one
additional virtual Photon exchange for
example in other words atom equals atom
with a virtual Photon exchange added
and the definition of atom you know the
bound State atom positronium whatever
the heck it is is that thing that you
get that it solves the equation x equals
f of x
okay yep and
you know
it's
by the way
let me think I'm trying to remember in
the original
you know in kind of
how does that relate to the diagonal
argument
in
well anyway I mean it's it's a thing
where people do this they say we will
Define self-consistently x equals f of x
uh
uh I guess you are then interested in
finding some sort of fixed point a
solution of the question yeah exactly
but the the whole point is that what
we're doing okay you can think of the
whole operation of open language as
solving the equation x equals a vowel of
x
foreign
that's what we do
right we're solving that equation
but our representation of solving that
equation is much more the unraveled
fixed point of a vowel operating on blah
blah blah
you see what I'm saying
and it's just a question of how you
represent it I mean you know and this is
why I'm asking Nick to justify you know
because because you can do something
more General than just x equals f of x
you can do much more complicated things
as you're doing x equals f of x and x
and all kinds of stuff like this so what
I'm trying to understand is you know
there is a model of doing this which is
a fixed Point single way computation
which is x equals f of x
you've got a different form of
evaluation here that's something more
complicated I'm trying to understand
what that's good for
Nick
whoa
um
well it's a Well if we could actually
solve such equations like this one
so I can principle
there could be like some solver that
given a lazy expression with
self-reference it may be some operators
like that actually
come up with a solution closed form
but it's not General the case I I know I
know this is what I keep on saying this
is what look if we could invent
an analog of transpinite numbers
to be trans-finite expressions
right then we would have solutions to a
large class of equations like this
am I making sense
but the theory of trans-finite
Expressions which I don't even think
that term existed before a minute ago
you know
is we don't have a theory of
transplanted expressions
and what you're saying is what you've
got is a very delicate fragile
representation of transfinite
expressions
we did discuss something like that in
the past once in relation to the join of
two infinite lengths
how to refer to the position of the
first element of the second list yes
right I mean that's a very basic
transformative expression question
well this is kind of an example of that
so you can have built-in
just for the length case
how to represent
some kind of transparent number if you
have an infinite list
and this would be
what on Earth is that
they call this represented
what is not
it's like a special
rapper that low special type that length
is returned so that you can do like
feed it again to the range so if you
have an infinite list and you want a
length of it it will return a nut which
kind of like
iterate and wrap this infinite list
against construct even use it as a new
range for example
although although it seems like the net
you know either it's going to be a
finite range in which case you could
just represent it with a pair of
integers or three integers or something
like that or it's going to be infinite
in which case if it's anything other
than what alif zero
you're in trouble right because you know
it doesn't make sense to have an
uncountable range
well I understand with range
yes I understand there's a complication
here because the content of the range is
ordinals the length of the range may be
Cardinals but the content is ordinals
well no no but the the point is you
can't have a a an uncountable lazy list
because it has a you know first element
and a second element yeah sure sure
no but I'm saying that the N the element
you know you can imagine
this is where I'm it's confusing between
Cardinal ordinal numbers the actual
elements of the infinite range go to
Omega you know Omega squared Epsilon
zero blah blah blah right but if we say
how long is that list the answer is LF
zero
and if we see exactly how ordinals and
Cardinals work yes indeed but but if you
say I want to index into that list I
want to get
see this is why I'm now totally confused
let's say I want to have a part
extractor that extracts Omega squared
foreign
what the heck is the part that you give
because the part you should give should
be a cardinal shouldn't it
and yet there is no Cardinals a size
that you give is just a value right but
but they're ordinals so Parts because
they are ordered they are ordinals
yeah so the the element that we were
discussing would be Omega yeah and there
is this question that Omega plus 1 is
not the same as one plus Omega indeed
right but but you're saying that I can
give part numbers I could give
trans-finite part numbers
right right but the bigger thing is this
is actually a little bit analogous to
there was a summer school project uh
that was vaguely related to this I mean
where there was the issue of basically
you have a set of things I think it was
diffusable numbers and and you have to
uh you want to be able to basically ask
for the you know
Omega Square fusible number or the Omega
plus one diffusable number or whatever
but I mean as though I think will be the
case in most situations like this even
if you have a way of representing the
the trans-finite
index effectively
it's it's there isn't really a general
way of being able to then like
you know if you just have an expression
for like like it's easy to write an
expression where you say you give me the
end where n is an integer you know uh
thing and I'll I'll give you the value
for it it's hard to then say give me n
where n is any sort of trans-finite
ordinal and I'll give you a value it's
hard to express that function
yeah
well okay look okay I think I think we'd
probably mind this about as far as we
can right now
I'm not
I mean
I'm fairly confused how this fits in to
I mean as a piece of language design
I understand what this is
the experience with such things in the
past
my experience with such things has not
been very good
but
you know there's always a
look I mean for many years I didn't
believe in associations because the
experience with associations in SNP was
bad
so it doesn't mean that it's necessary
just because it's been implemented badly
before doesn't mean it's a bad idea but
I don't I don't really get this you know
I don't see how one's going to turn this
into I mean you know what we're trying
to do with multi-computation right now
is
you know if we think about it in
chemistry or in economics or in one of
these other areas we're imagining what
are the programming elements that we
want to use to represent
multi-computational kinds of things just
like in
you know okay so here's a here's a
question
uh
I don't really have all these analogies
properly understood
you know cellular automata turned out to
be a pretty good
minimalized model of kind of parallel
computation single way evaluation
there are a zillion other things you
could imagine
that are just like I take various pieces
of data and I munch it up and I get the
next thing they're not as useful
for multi-composition we have the kind
of the strings case we have the numbers
case we have the hypergraph case
but if we want something that is a more
structured example of multi-computation
that's kind of what we're doing by
saying expression-based
multi-computation
and again how does one go multi answer
number one we have sort of the the
multi-way
Nest case we've got the multi-way
replace case we've got the implicit
multi-ism from pattern matching
and
I'm just I I don't know I mean maybe
there's a way
I'm really confused here this is
you know the other way to go multi is to
say my fundamental evaluation process is
defined by some essentially multi
you know self-consistent equation
so I think what you're doing here
so is that right
well
it's close yeah if you actually have an
applied
problem that you want to solve that's
what you
probably but I mean this is the point
that that I mean you know do we do we
believe if we are thinking about the
roulette we're thinking about n machines
we're thinking about I don't know
they're improving we're thinking about
meta mathematics we're thinking about
chemistry you know can we think about
those in terms of these self-consistent
equations
I think we are I'll have to think about
that I mean I've always been thinking
about some of this in terms of
functional equations
I'll have to think about self-consistent
equations
I mean
it's like functional equations okay the
number of functional equations that can
be solved in reasonable closed form is
incredibly small
right
that
I guess it depends very much on the
properties of the f whether it's a
contraction mapping and it has fixed
points and things like that
yes I think so
but but the problem is that while there
might be a lovely fixed Point theorem
for for certain cases by the time you
can do the general case which is what
Nick is showing here of x equals F of Y
of X of Etc et cetera Etc I just think
you'll never it's very rare to be able
to resolve that
yeah that I agree
and so I I just don't get unless we have
a way of representing General
transplanted expressions in a way I mean
this is what you know Roger has pushed
extensively in uh you know in things
like you know it started with algebraic
numbers it's then uh you know
differential root objects and things
like this his point is it's trivial to
just say oh yeah well we've got a
differential equation that we can't
solve great just imagine the solution to
the differential equation and call it
Foo okay that's not very useful what
becomes useful is if you can have a nice
canonical representation of Foo and you
can combine Foo and bar and so on and
you can start having a whole calculus
around these things then it becomes
useful am I making sense
so just saying you can in principle
Define this thing as oh well I'm going
to call the solution of the equation
blah isn't very useful now so if we
could Define a theory of transparent
Expressions that represents relations
between these things and ways to combine
them and so on like if you take two of
these things what can you do with them
can you combine them in any way
Nick well
it's like like we did
here for example why not
this is we combine them
okay
fair enough we're just programming with
lazy Expressions it's not not a big deal
we just taken reference each other
they're not evaluate on their own until
you ask it
query it
so I think it's a very well would you
find Paradigm of programming in general
and it
can be generalized too much computation
I think
just have to think about it well no no
wait wait a minute wait a minute wait a
minute your main point is
you're saying X is lazily defined to be
blah
I mean yes all those definitions can be
lazy
and then
I mean yes that's fine
I
I don't know how useful this is
because as I say most cases that I know
of
you know other than toys
I mean it's just like okay I I'm you
know with logic programming for example
for like 25 years people would show me
this stuff and it's like oh what can you
show okay we'll look at the end Queen's
problem okay yes we can do that one look
at this problem that problem and there
were like four toy problems people would
show
and then it's like well what else can
you do with it oh well it always blows
up in practice and in practice we just
write regular code
so that's what we're trying to avoid
it's not very useful to do things like
that
so you know there may be some great
thing here I mean the thing that we have
learned
you know the thing that came out with
combinators for example is there are
plenty of infinite combinator
expressions
which we understand not at all what to
do with them
like we would like to understand them we
just don't
you know like the canonical forms
problem you know are these two
combinator expressions the same up to
some you know in other words given given
two things could we for example have a
simplifier that says represented in lazy
form these two expressions are you know
one is blah and the other is you know
two plus blah
am I making sense
that will be useful I think it's super
hard but it's useful
right right
so I mean look look we really need to we
know we have some paths that lead to
definitely useful things
it's fine to investigate this but I we
just kind of need to know
you know
I I don't get it I don't get how this is
useful I don't get how it connects to
other things sorry I you know is there
something I'm missing here
I mean yes you can Define it I
understand you can Define this
but what
you know
where will it be used where could it be
used
well ideally it does like some kind of
domain specific language that you can
use because it's like you can use it
again in Haskell you can like hold the
programming there is just with the same
kind of lazy Expressions too I
understand I know that version and you
can solve problems in there okay give me
an example of something impressive
and don't say you can generate the
primes because I know that
well that's well that's something that
isn't just a demo I mean look to give
you an example of this you know
as which I've probably given 75 times
you know in SMP I had a whole bunch of
evaluation control stuff and there was
this one example of being able to do
Foster Fibonacci numbers using
evaluation control you know using
recursion control evaluation
but that was the only freaking example
everything else was it was just a toy
well I think we we will come up with the
same kind of issue with whatever we
invent it's like you have to switch to
the whole world view in order to I know
so I'm asking I mean you know the thing
that we've done is we understand more
about multi-computation now because
we've got real examples of it we've got
plenty of real examples
so we actually you know implementing
multi-computation makes sense because we
have a world view around it
okay implementing self-referential
computation we don't have a world view
around that at this time and not as
anybody else
you know it's a slow process to get a
world view around something and it may
or may not be useful I mean you know to
give a good example trans finite numbers
have been around for 140 years
and they're not widely used for
practical things
you know I I kind of feel like these
infinite data structure things and
transplanted expressions are a place
where they might finally get used in
practice but we're not there yet
well self-inflation stuff is not the
only thing that it's
happening here right it's like laser
range doesn't
or lazilies doesn't self-reference
itself
I know but lazy list is a different
thing which can be dealt with more
pragmatically I mean in other words you
can sign up for this more General thing
that is then just fragile and explosive
and not useful or you can sign up for
something more modest I mean it's just
like you know we could have signed up
for in the original wolf and language
evaluator we could have signed up for a
multi-way evaluator from day one
okay it wouldn't have been useful nobody
would have understood anything
well how's the difference
no
because we understand much more about
multi-computation now
I mean this is what we're trying to do
is is we understand more about
multi-computation we're trying to
leverage that to make a multi-way
evaluator that is you know now more
comprehensible and we and we have a
better understanding I mean in the past
this question of you know what do the
evaluation fronts look like Etc et
cetera et cetera we just had no way to
think about that no way to think about
it we could just say depth first breath
first that was about it
right we at least now understand that
that's related to things like reference
frames and general activity and so on
okay metrics and you know coordination
choices and all that kind of stuff now
in principle we could have understood
that 40 years ago but we didn't
right so that's that's the opportunity
now
to move forward on that on that kind of
thing but we don't have a way to
understand the general self-reference
thing
those are different from just
programming with the inclusion like we
have a recursion limit problems
so it's isn't it the same kind of thing
but here you just have an additional
control over it if you don't have a
self-reference this is an iteration
the whole point is look recursion limit
is a mess
recursion limit is a hack that and the
most interesting feature of that hack is
it hasn't bitten our heads off so to
speak
in other words there's been a hack in
the system for 35 years
but most people don't run into it
because most programming doesn't Ram its
you know knows into that issue
right but if you define a mode of
programming where every time you use it
you get rammed into something which is a
big mess it will not be useful
right we've managed to have a style of
programming where yes there is a you
know a corner case where things blow up
but it isn't the general case
I'm just I'm just not seeing this I mean
I you know we've got an opportunity to
actually take multi-computation that's
what I want us to be doing to actually
take multi-computation which we now have
a better understanding of and make it so
that it is usable for programming this
is something different that yes we could
have had I mean people it's just like
when I first developed SMP and
theoretical computer scientists said
your language is impossible
like really why well because you can
Define x equals X plus one and it will
blow up
it's like okay that's true turns out
in you know between that and woven
language we've got 40 something years of
experience in using these things and the
fact that x equals X plus one blows up
does not cause the language to be
unusable
but except if you say the primary way
you're programming is to walk right at
the edge of the precipice of x equals X
plus one then you're going to have
something that blows up all the time and
it's not useful
that's I mean the the art of the design
of the language is to make it so that
most of the time people are not walking
on the edge of a precipice
station may be
quite on edge I I know I know but the
whole point is we know we have methods
for dealing with it that are not this
that allow you to make progress with
multi-computation in a way that people
understand the goal of the language
design is to not you know if we push
people to the edge of the precipice and
then say okay now you've got
multi-computation but you're on the edge
of the precipice it's just going to fail
the goal is to give them
multi-computation in a way so that
they're not dangling you know at the
over the edge of the precipice
and that's that's what we were trying to
get a design for and that's why we've
talked about I mean I was not thrilled
to have to introduce all this lazy stuff
as part of that because I don't think
it's really to the point I think it's
something that seems to be necessary to
make it work efficiently and so on and
perhaps necessary as a way to think
about it but you know to throw in this
direction just doesn't seem it's just
not going to work
at least I don't see how to make it work
I mean maybe there's a way to make it
work but I don't know what is the
alternative Define super functions
yes the way of programming in general
are quite much expectation no yes the
way to start is
just like Nest list and Nest graph are
useful functions for all kinds of things
you know Nest list is a useful
essentially meta modeling primitive for
all kinds of things you know all kinds
of cellular automata Turing machines
whatever else they're all basically
nestless operations
okay Nest graph is the beginnings of a
multi-computational version of that
only the beginnings not a very you know
as we know it doesn't have it doesn't
work quite correctly for that that's
what we want to generalize
right if we could get the thing that we
talked about many times here multi-way
Nest multi-way replace and so on that's
that's what we need to do because that
leverages the stuff we Now understand
about multi-computation and doesn't just
throw us over this precipice
I think we should just should solve an
actual problem before coming up we have
a plenty of actual problems to solve
we've got to focus on some of them no no
but we we we know what we need we've got
tons of places where we've used our
hackerly built multi-way functions
multi-way system functions to do all
kinds of things with the physics project
in this project and that project all
over the place right the first step is
to clean that up that's what I've wanted
to do for the last many months because
we know that that is a use case it makes
sense it works we just don't have a
clean language design for it
in other words just being able to get
you know bronchial graphs from you know
uh you know hypergraphy writing Etc et
cetera et cetera that's already a useful
use case
and the point is the use case for
multi-computation is different from the
use case for single way computation it
isn't give me the answer it's these more
complicated things like give me
branchial graphs
right and the good news is and the
reason that I wanted to push this
project the good news is we already know
what we want because we've got hundreds
maybe thousand examples of actual we
made this picture this is what we wanted
to do they're just not made in a very
elegant way
and I'm making sense
well I still struggle to like
to find one useful example apart from
picture generation
well I mean you could take the well I
don't know you could ask something about
you know the Confluence time or
something are they you know there are
all kinds of things which it happens
that pictures are a useful way to
represent these things
but we can obviously there's also
computation every computation everything
that we have in the function repository
around multi-way system and its helper
functions is what we're aiming for a
clean version of that is what we really
want to do
that's the first step
because those things we know the output
right we're not defining something where
the thing is is you know we we know
we're trying to do a certain class of
computations I mean look in my
experience in doing language design the
thing you have to have is a set of
computations you want to do and then you
figure out what is the elegant way to do
those computations we have a set of
computations we want to do we've got
functions to do the computation they're
just not terribly elegant and that's
what we need to focus on it was it's a
good thing to explore is there a more
General formalism and I just don't think
this one is working
and I you know I think that it's nice
it's fine but it's not the thing I mean
it's you know
look
raw arbitrary unchecked computation is
not human accessible
and you can Define plenty of computation
where humans just say well I don't know
what's going on
that's not useful language design
right and so so you know as I say the
main thing that caused me to want to do
this project is that we have many
examples now of actual useful
multi-computational stuff to do and
that's what we need to get language
design around
which is it's most of the stuff we've
done is just picture generation it's
like
even
it's like apartment maybe from
like whatever I mean it's the same thing
you've got proofs you've got this you've
got that you've got you know find a
number that satisfies this thing that is
generated in this way I mean it doesn't
you know there's there's many
Communications we've successfully
defined plenty of computations to do so
yes many of them generate pictures
because a very common structure is not
an answer you know okay you can talk
about computation typical computation
say
what do you want to generate in
computation
well at times people said I want to
generate a number I said well I want to
generate a list of numbers
well maybe I want to generate a graph
it so happens that with
multi-computation it is more common to
want to generate a graph which we
usually show as a picture than it is did
you want to generate a number
but we could perfectly well generate
numbers if we wanted to and we have done
in many cases
you know I mean if you look at the stuff
I did with combinations there's tons of
places where we generate numbers if you
want numbers out it's not necessarily
the most useful thing but it's the thing
you can do
or will you generate accommodate your
Expressions out
anyway look I mean this is why I wanted
to get you know this is why the original
project was a clean language design for
the multi-computational functions that
we already have
and look I think what you know what
you've successfully done here is to show
a direction which is interesting
I don't think you have convincingly
shown that it is a better way in any way
to to understand how to do this kind of
computation and I think we should go to
what we were originally trying to do
which is to make a clean language design
for the multi-computation that we
already know we want to do and I don't
think self-reference is going to help us
I could be proved wrong and you might
have in this meeting you might have
proved me wrong but you haven't
yeah so I mean you know that there may
be something we're missing there may be
some great language design idea I don't
think there is
I think this is one of these ideas
that's been around like like
transplanted numbers have been around
for 140 years and nobody's you know
they just haven't quite landed this is
another thing that hasn't quite landed
maybe in 50 years it will
but um maybe in two years it will but it
hasn't yet
great ideas about design
of those General functions that we
already
we went through the design months ago we
have a design just needs to be
implemented and as we implement it we're
going to see lots of details
we have a design it's this
multi-computation you know this
computation object Etc et cetera Etc we
have a design
I mean like that multi-object
should we
I think it's something let's not go
we're aware over time here okay let's
let's let's I think I think this is um
uh
yeah memes is commenting that it's it's
also relates to Jonathan's work on
category Theory yeah I mean yes there
are relations there also and and these
string diagrams and so on are another
thing but they're all different it's all
different but the focus I don't think
this focus on self-referential
structures is right
okay I could be proved wrong but I don't
think it's right
all right we should wrap up here
um anybody got any final comments
no okay I I really really really would
like to see the things that we had
designed several months ago actually
implemented I really really want to see
that happen it's really kind of
important that that happened
um
so okay all right let's wrap up here
thanks okay see you all soon